The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political commentary with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled Authority stock up
on your summer reading with a 12 week
subscription in print and online for
just pile pounds plus we'll send you a
copy of Spectator columnist Lionel
Shrivers new book the motion of the body
through space absolutely free go to
spectator coudl UK forward slash Lionel
hello and welcome to The Spectator I'm
Frasier Nelson for our audio reads this
week we've got Douglas smarty reading
his cover story in defense of liberalism
then we've got Matthew Paris who takes a
rather different view and celebrates the
toppling of statues an exhilarating form
of art he says and finally
Kate Andrews our economics correspondent
on what she thinks people in her site or
the political divides don't quite
understand about what's happening in her
native America first
Douglas Murray it has become fashionable
in recent years to talk of the death of
liberalism but as crowds high on the
octane of generational
self-righteousness rampage through major
cities the evidence mounts the growing
intolerance of freedom of thought the
inability to talk across divides the way
that most of the British establishment
police included feels the need to pledge
fealty to the cause as though all
terrified of ending up on the wrong side
points to a crisis of more than
confidence it is evidence of an
underlying morbidity each day the
Cultural Revolution is picking up a pace
with the iconoclasts who attacked the
Cenotaph and the statue of Winston
Churchill looking for new focuses for
their rage the University of Liverpool
has announced that its Gladstone halls
of residence will be renamed after
protesters pointed out that the former
Prime Minister's father had owned slaves
so there goes the sins of the father
ethic too nervous broadcasters have
started removing programs ahead of any
Stampede with the BBC withdrawing Little
Britain and HBO taking out Gone with the
Wind from their streaming services in
case the woke I of sour on flashes on
them what we are seeing is nothing more
or less than the death of the liberal
mind of course liberalism was always a
broadly defined term
a definition made only vaguer by
Americans making it synonymous with
left-wing but in the truest political
sense it encapsulates most of the
foundations of our political order
including though not limited to equality
the rule of law and freedom including
the freedom of speech that allows good
ideas to win out in the past few years
left-wing critics have been keen to
identify what they see as the erasure of
liberal democracy by popularly elected
leaders on the political right but in
our own country the much more serious
assault on political liberalism comes
not from the conservative right but from
the radical left over the past couple of
weeks well-meaning people have poured
almost a million pounds into the coffers
of black lives matter UK in the belief
that they are helping a movement that
will help black people in fact they have
funded a deeply radical movement on its
own fundraising page BLM UK describes
its aims as to dismantle imperialism
capitalism white supremacy patriarchy
and the state structures so as well as
dismantling a non-existent menace
imperialism it intends to bring down the
economy and completely alter relations
between the sexes negatively
characterized as patriarchy this is not
liberalism but far-left
radicalism of a kind that has become
very familiar of late some people
watching events of recent days will have
been surprised by how far and fast such
sentiments of run by the sight of a mob
in Bristol tearing down a statue and
then jumping on it by a Labour MP saying
I celebrate these acts of resistance we
need a movement that will tear down
systemic racism by the ranks of British
police who could find no way to respond
to this behavior other than in a newly
invented act of faith to take the knee
before it
and then there is the media which has
chosen to provide cover for such
violence and purge from their ranks not
just people who dissent from it but in
the case of the New York Times a few
days ago anyone who helps publish
someone who descends as one of the last
liberals left of that newspaper
Barry Weiss explained it last week the
over 40's in the news business like so
many others imagined that the people
coming up under them shared their
liberal worldview then they discovered
that these young people believed in
safety ISM over liberalism and the right
of people to feel emotionally and
psychologically safe over what were
considered core liberal values like free
speech actually the divide is even
bigger than that and now encompasses
nearly everything where the liberal mind
is enquiring the woke mind is dogmatic
where the liberal mind is capable of
humility the woke mind is capable of
none where the liberal mind is able to
forgive the woke mind believes that to
have erred just once is caused enough to
be canceled and while the liberal mind
inherited the idea of loving your
neighbor the woke mind positively itches
to cast the first stone readers of The
Spectator have known this was coming
when this magazine first wrote about the
Stepford students it was asked why we
take this so seriously
surely the students would grow up and
they did but they didn't change the
virtue signaling of large corporations
for growing legions of diversity
officers and implicit bias training was
also written off as the silliness of the
corporate world when we described the
mandatory requirement in government to
prove a commitment to diversity in order
to be eligible for any public
appointment it was greeted with the same
dismissal as the American
journalist Andrew Sullivan himself now
seemingly muzzled if not canceled put it
two years ago we all live on campus now
step by step the UK came to have a
public and private sector dedicated to
the implementation of views which are
barely distinguishable from those of the
protesters who took to the streets in
the past week or two it's an ethic which
demands that our society play a set of
impossible unwinnable games of identity
and privilege that not only subvert but
end any idea of Tolerance all of this
emanates from those who come out of
university educated to loathe our
society believing it to be characterized
by the oppression of certain groups by
other groups a shameful history and a
shameful present today these people head
into professions where their language of
aggressive superiority educate yourself
is used to intimidate their elders force
everyone to agree with their point of
view and otherwise make themselves
unsayable as we all movements of catch
they aren't on to nothing
inequalities and inequities do exist
here as in all societies reasonable
people disagree about how to address
this but the new illiberal radicals do
not share that worry for them every
inequity that exists financial familial
social neurological is the result of the
same thing discrimination a thing we
must tackle eradicate and otherwise
cleanse from existence there's an awful
lot of work to do even the woke analysis
of history that now sees them scouring
the land for more statues to assault is
radically different from that of the
liberal mind liberals understand that
people in history acted with the
knowledge they had at the time and
that the task of those looking back is
to look on it with understanding not
least in the hope of being understood in
turn the woke mind abhors this it knows
that it is right and that everybody
before this year zero was a bigot
after the weekends vandalism against
London monuments the Capitals Mayor
Sadiq Khan announced that his Commission
for diversity in the public realm would
sit in judgment on all racist statues in
the capital within hours the Museum of
London had already brought him the
cranes to remove an errant statue on
West India key in such ways has a free
exchange of ideas about our past and
present been replaced by a series of
demands and assertions that demand
everyone else's compliance silence is
violence is one favored line meaning
that if you do not agree with the
radicals you are perpetrating an act of
violence
naturally this assertion comes from the
same people who have spent a lot of time
asserting that words such as
misgendering someone are violence while
the violence of the past few days is not
violence it is on the lip of this trap
that our representatives and public
figures have teetered over the past week
or two unable to work out how they can
avoid a step they into it to be deadly
what they need to do is pause and
fundamentally change the terms basing
their appeal not just on reason but on a
truly liberal spirit it should be one
which emphasizes that the claims being
made are unjust it is unjust to portray
the whole of American society in all of
its complexity as typifies by a
policeman who is awaiting trial for
murder and it is even more
just to think that his actions reveal
some deep truth about the British police
or the British state let alone everybody
who is white equally it is not just
unjust but vindictive to pretend that
any contradiction of your worldview is
merely a display of white privilege
white fragility or white tears
unwittingly or otherwise those who use
these terms subvert one of the last
great additions to liberal thought that
aspiration expressed by dr. Martin
Luther King half a century ago for when
dr. King talked about the need to judge
a person by the content of their
character and not by the color of their
skin he gave us something that was not
just a great moral insight but in an
increasingly diverse society the only
solution a year before his death dr.
King gave a speech titled where do we go
from here in which he said let us be
dissatisfied until that day when nobody
will shout white power when nobody will
shout black power but everybody will
talk about God's power and human power
the people who have come after dr. King
have spent their years busily inverting
that dream in the name of black agency
they try to deny white people agency in
the name of assailing white supremacy
they end up by asserting black supremacy
and in order to make up for the
sufferings of people who are no longer
alive they demand vast wealth transfers
today based on racial grouping it is
hard to imagine a more divisive program
all carried out in the name of anti
racism what they are actually doing is
busily re racializing our society
it is which is how you come to the
situation where a cabinet minister is
quizzed on Sky News about the precise
ethno racial composition of the British
Cabinet and certain anti-racists can be
found on social media noting with
disapproval the number of people of
Asian descent in the cabinet any
movement that says things are so bad
that this whole thing needs to be pulled
down should be encouraged to realise
before they have to experience it the
cost of what they are abandoning and to
remember the central truth about how
much easier it is to pull down than it
is to build they must be responded to by
people of every skin color and
background with a polite but firm no not
just because the things that they are
attempting to pull down include the only
things that are capable of holding us
all up
but because if everything that got us
here was so bad then what we are living
in wouldn't be so unusually good that
was Douglas money and now Matthew Paris
I couldn't disagree more with sakir
stahma it was completely wrong it
shouldn't have been done in that way or
with Boris Johnson if people wanted the
removal of the statue there are
democratic roots that can be followed no
there was something magnificent about
the site of the Bristol Mob throwing
into the harbor the statue of a man
whose trade was notorious for throwing
six slaves with no monetary value into
the sea 1890s Britain raised that statue
1890s Britain the decade in which my
grandparents were children for heaven's
sake had only just closed the slave
market in Zanzibar and if you want to
know more about that stain on our fairly
recent history read Aleister Hazel's
enthralling horrifying the last slave
market
dr. John Kirk and the struggle to end
the East African slave trade if we're
entitled to feel pride at the
achievements and virtues of our
forebears why should we not feel shame
at their sins
if there is significance in erecting
monuments to those we admire who can
deny the significance of tearing down
monuments to those we don't be honest
the sculpting of a massive
representation of Sir Edward Colston for
public display was not an exercise in
either history or biography it was a
salutation plain and simple and if 1890s
Britain was free to raise a monument to
a man whom many of the residents of
Bristol wished to salute 2020s Britain
should be free to raise two fingers to a
man whose memory their successors hate
toppling that statue was not an attempt
to erase history as disgruntled
conservatives liked to mutter of history
the moving finger writes and having writ
moves on nor all thy piety nor wit shall
Lear it back to cancel hath align nor
all thy tears wash out a word of it no
that statue was not about history but
estimation our era is entitled to its
own response far from this being a
writing out of history it was a writing
in of history history is what happened
how dreary then to recommend that
instead of letting people show that
passion unbidden and unmerited the
statue should instead have been demoted
by a deliberative committee of municipal
were these followed by the sending of a
van with council workers in high-vis
jackets and the dispatch of the bronze
to some dull and unvisited corner of a
museum somewhere Sir Edward went out not
with a whimper but with a bang and the
video of that statue going into the
harbor is now already in the modern
Museum that is the internet that day has
become itself history history made not
by an item on the agenda for councillors
and bureaucrats but by the impulse of an
angry crowd watching the video scene of
the mob toppling the bronze Sir Edward
over the key side last week I felt a
kind of thrill at the beating heart of
human beings responding viscerally to a
piece of art the statue of course was no
more than an item of fairly
unexceptional art it served as proxy as
heroic sculpture does for its subject in
this case Sir Edward but then serving as
proxy for the things that may represent
is what a great deal of art is all about
just as it is good when art lifts
inspires in Nobles and pleases us it's
good to when art infuriates hurts or in
flames
good in both cases because art has
engaged as something in me resonates at
people's rage against a material object
serving as proxy for what they hate so I
also thrilled to people's rage against
art itself art they do not like for this
to is a function of art to engage in
November 1954 on his 80th birthday
Winston Churchill was formally presented
with his portrait by one of our most
notable 20th century artists sir Graham
Sutherland the painting in my view a
masterpiece is of a figure at the same
time peevish and heroic obdurate and
defiant
fat bull-necked and irascible with a
hint of hurt in the eyes the portrait is
completely and infuriatingly him his
political enemies tended to think it was
rather good his friends mostly took the
other view Churchill detested it said it
made him look like a drunk propped up
from the gutter accepted this gift of
both houses of parliament with what
grace he could muster not a lot
took it to Chartwell and sent it down
into the basement after a lady Spenser
Churchill's death it emerged that she
had had it removed and burnt I call that
act of aggression against art a triumph
for art art should delight wound or
enrage
lady Spencer Churchill's vandalism was
the ultimate tribute to honest
portraiture I see the whole episode as a
celebration of the power of figurative
representation to arouse passion in the
breasts of the viewer and passion will
take its natural course
Sutherlands art had cut his subject to
the quick Sutherland was entitled to his
artistic response to Churchill and the
Churchill's were entitled to their
response to him this is where art should
be not on elaborate plinths or the walls
of hushed galleries but at the center of
attention and human passion whether the
passion is sympathetic or antipathetic
his secondary heroic sculpture is
multidisciplinary hovering between art
craftsmanship and historical tribute
Colston's bronze like Sutherlands oils
is at commentary to see these
commentaries engulfed in the flames of a
wife's anger or drowned by the Bristol
Ian's in Bristol Harbor is to see art
come out of the galleries and text books
and tourist snapshots and into our
hearts and spleens thus perished most of
the innumerable monuments to General
Franco that I remember from parks and
squares in pre-1970 Spain thus came down
the statue of Saddam Hussein whose
toppling in Baghdad was so far as I
remember unaccompanied by much regret
from we who are of a conservative habit
of mind and thus fell a slave traders
monument in the destruction of art's
handiwork art shows it matters comes
alive that's was Matthew Paris and
finally Kate's Andrews America can often
look to outsiders like a country of two
warring tribes the Trump --is-- anti PC
Brigade and the woke Twitterati such
divisions certainly exists our
broadcasters our party political and
partisanship is deeply entrenched in
America's two-party system it's tempting
to see the scenes in recent weeks as the
continuation of tribal warfare by
there means but the truth is far more
complicated America has the most
militarized and aggressive police force
in the Western world the country's
legacy of rapid expansion combined with
vast geography and open landscapes
engendered a sense of lawlessness early
on and need to be protected from it this
has led to an implicit social contract
police need to be armed to match the
criminals they're dealing with it's the
price for keeping the country safe
when the police bought vehicles that
look like tanks or dressed as if they
were off to war we didn't ask questions
in theory you knew it must go wrong
sometimes but what did going wrong look
like who did it effect it was hard to
imagine no longer the ubiquity of
smartphones means misdeeds are now
filmed and shared instantly we see
America's police officers treat
low-level offenders and even innocent
citizens with the same force and
aggression you would expect to see used
against the most violent criminals black
Americans feel the overwhelming brunt of
the brutality when the system goes wrong
they suffer the most it's a common trap
- plans that cherry-pick statistics and
say nothing to see black Americans are
no more likely to be shot by police than
they were five years ago most who were
shot were carrying guns 14 of the 55
unarmed Americans shot by police last
year were black but despite accounting
for 13% of the population African
Americans make up more than a quarter of
the thousand fatal police shootings that
take place each year an unarmed black
man is four times more likely to be
fatally shot than his white counterpart
over the past two decades nearly 30,000
Americans have been registered dead at
the hands of police causes of death
include tasers strongholds and head
injury there is now growing awareness of
these tactics and it's forcing us to ask
are we okay with this
George Floyd was killed by a cops knee
shoved into his neck for nearly ten
minutes he died by asphyxiation not a
gunshot so his death wouldn't be
registered on the fatal shootings list
but it registered with the nation
showing how out of hand police brutality
is in America it fits
trend earlier in lockdown a mod Arbor II
a 25 year old black man was shot dead by
a former police man and his son while
out jogging in Georgia then there was
Elijah Tufano 14 punched and roughed up
by a California cop for possession of a
cigar and Floyd is not the first time
we've heard I can't breathe on camera
Eric Gardner uttered the same word six
years ago when the police put him in a
chokehold and strangled him to death for
selling single cigarettes on the street
after protests Floyd's killer was
charged so too were the cops who looked
on their action and inaction exposes a
culture one that has been allowed to
exist because not enough Americans
thought it worth confronting their
action and inaction exposes a culture
one that has been allowed to exist
because not enough Americans thought it
worth confronting and of course far-left
protesters have joined the marches but
to focus on them is fundamentally to
misunderstand what's happening it's not
about the murder of one man but the
countless black men Floyd's death
represents and the Warped social
contract that has allowed it to happen
the justice reforms of the 1980s and
1990s have had the unintended effect of
worsening race relations Bill Clinton's
war on drugs using prison as its main
tool disproportionately puts black
Americans behind bars drugs are used and
sold equally by black and white
Americans but black Americans are six
times more likely to be incarcerated for
a drug offense meanwhile the Supreme
Court's establishment of qualified
immunity for the police allows officers
to only face punishment if their crime
clearly infringes on an established
often technical right this has
encouraged appalling excesses that's why
we find former presidents George W Bush
and Barack Obama calling for policy
reform and why former presidential
candidate Mitt Romney was out on a March
hosted by an openly left-wing campaign
group the right and left divide has
broken down these past few weeks
driven by America's collective memory of
its history of racism what England
remembers is the Victorian era Americans
remember as a time of slavery and the
Civil War Jim Crow was in living
as our parents and grandparents join
Martin Luther King jr. to march on
Washington it's fresh and Ross still in
a way that is unique to the nation the
protests in Britain as in America have
been used as cover for those with an
agenda of violence and destruction but
most people marching will have done so
in sympathy with America and to
highlight issues that also exist in the
UK and there's one key difference in
both countries we have seen videos of
people throwing themselves between
protesters and police but in the UK
protesters have been stepping in to
protect the police from stones and glass
bottles to this American it was a very
moving sight that emphasized the
differences between policing and my
homeland and my adopted country America
is policed by force while the UK is
policed by consent something worth
holding on to that was Kate Andrews and
that's all for this week he thanks very
much for listening and thanks to our
producer agus Carter
The Spectator magazine combines incisive
political commentary with books and arts
reviews of unrivaled Authority stock up
on your summer reading with a 12 week
subscription in print and online for
just pile pounds plus we'll send you a
copy of Spectator columnist Lionel
Shrivers new book the motion of the body
through space absolutely free go to
spectator coudl UK forward slash Lionel